- Hey, come on in.
(cheerful 80's pop synth music)
Yeah, Push & Believe.
You got it.
I've been busy doing
these interviews,
got a lot of shows going on.
- [Sean] Right.
- [Brody] We're both getting
ready for a Half Hour.
- [Sean] Yes, we are.
- [Brody] I know we're
pressed for time.
I have to iron my shirt,
if you don't mind.
- You know, a lot of people
don't realize the stress
of wrinkly clothing.
- [Brody] No!
Woah, it's hot, it's a
little hot, but not where
it needs to be.
We're gonna add
some steam to it.
So you're from New Orleans.
- Yes I am.
- [Brody] Were you
there for Katrina?
- I was.
- What did you do, take cover?
- I was at a bar, and the
bar said it was going to
stay open all night.
It was a "Fuck Hurricane
Katrina" party.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, I'm dead serious.
- I, okay.
- We were hanging out, we
were drinking pitchers of PBR
and then they started
walking in sheets of plywood
and they started
boarding up the windows.
- It's getting serious.
- And they're like,
"You should probably
"get the fuck out of
here," and you're like,
"Well, now I'm wasted."
- Right, now they want you
to drunk drive on the 10.
- But, you know what, I did.
- Really?
- [Sean] And just hauled ass
to Baton Rouge.
- And you made it out?
Did you leave your
belongings back at home?
- I got the essentials,
and got the.
- Toothbrush, toothpaste,
floss, hair gel.
- Come on, one more.
- Exfoliant.
- Exfoliant, you
got it, nailed it.
- You gotta get rid of
the dead skin cells.
- You gotta exfoliate when
you're running from a hurricane.
- You ever see Emeril
around New Orleans?
- Nah, he doesn't live there?
- He doesn't live there?
- Nah, he doesn't live there.
- But he's from there!
- Nah, he's not from there.
- Bam!
Bam!
- Yeah!
- You know, Sean, I
know a lot about you
and I've done some extra
research and you're into
oral, anal action?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Can you expound on
that a little bit?
- There's something
about going there,
going to the most
disgusting, yet sense...
People don't realize,
the butthole's where
all the nerves are.
- Yeah, male and female.
- Yeah.
And if you really like
someone, you go there.
- Are you talking digits,
are you talking tongue?
- I recommend all.
- Wow.
- Go all 11 digits, you
know what I mean by 11.
- Woah, hello, take
it to another level,
you got it.
- Exactly.
And then, you know, if you
really like the person,
then you go tongue.
You have to really be into them.
- So tongue is after that.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- Really?
- Absolutely.
- I thought, I have
anal energies as well.
And I would personally,
if you asked me,
- Go tongue first,
and then that?
- Yeah, I would spread
cheek, and then I would
go in tongue, moisturize.
- You might be a
Renaissance man.
- So just about done with this.
Wrinkle free, you got it.
More than happy to
take care of you.
- [Sean] Would you?
- Yeah!
- I didn't want to ask.
- I'll get it, I'll get it,
no problem.
- Thank you.
Because this thing
is just, I mean.
- We're just gonna
get right here.
You know, this is what
comedians do for each other
when you go out on the road,
one guy's in the shower,
another guy's getting
ready and it's like,
you gotta work together.
- You got to.
- So listen, we're here
in Boston, we're doing
our Half Hours, Brody
Stevens, Sean Patton,
ironed shirts, positivity.
New Orleans, L.A.
Yes!
Push & Believe, you got it.
Anal energies.
What a great video.
Like it, subscribe, click it.
Comedy Central, in it.
Facebook, we got you covered.
Twitter, we're there too.
Friendship, I know you got that.
Tell everybody.
We're in this together.
It's teamwork, I scratch
your back, you shave mine.
Boom, laughter, you got it.
Click, subscribe, all that.
I'm gonna click, I'm gonna
believe, and you should too.
(stomach growling)